foreign
let's go to Z in Eugene Oregon what's up
Z
hey Dr John uh
so
um I recently came to find out about you
um I wrote Into the Ramsay show actually
because I was struggling quite a bit
and got uh directed to you and you guys
you got sent over to the B Team sorry
man no no no no they had very nice
things to say about Chelsea so
um and
started reading your book uh the the on
your past one
and it's been uh first just want to say
you have a very good writing ability I I
write I'm I have no books but you're a
good writer and a lot of the things that
I've read so far really like struck me
I'm as I'm going through I'm
highlighting things and
sharing things with other people where
I'm like is this not true it means the
world to me thank you man
yeah it's been a great book so far and
uh
uh chapter two especially really kind of
slapped me in the face a little bit and
I was like yeah okay well I don't feel
quite as crazy now because this is all
true
um
but uh just to give you like a little
bit of background about me
um
I'm 34 today is actually my birthday uh
happy birthday man
thank you it's it's it's been for quite
a while uh birthdays are tough
um
and I I don't know why but like so I was
born on Friday the 13th and now it's
Friday the 13th again and I'm like oh
this is a little strange but
um
they've they've become hard they've been
hard for years and years because uh in
my late teens
I started to have some struggles with
depression and it wasn't anything
really serious at the time but
uh then in like early 20s like 23 or so
it hit really hard to the point where uh
I had to go be put in the hospital and
put on suicide watch and all that kind
of fun stuff
um
and ever since then it's been uh
it's been a very long difficult struggle
it's been about 10 11 years of that
where
uh
it's just like walking through a desert
and and the worst part of all
um
so after my first like real battle with
major depression where it was just
sucking the life out of me completely
and nothing felt right and
um
you know you obviously are familiar with
what happens uh it it it felt like a
mental cancer to me is what it felt like
I don't know what cancer feels like but
mentally that's what I felt like I was
going through where I couldn't function
and I
nothing felt right and nothing feels
right
um
double click on that for a second so you
have a
is it that you are going through
experiences and that you
think should feel a certain way and your
body is just not responding with the
right feelings you hold somebody's hands
you kiss them in the words I've heard
often is I feel I feel nothing
like my heart rate doesn't get up and
the adrenaline doesn't pump up it's like
the I'm trying to start the car and it
won't start or like your legs feel like
concrete and you can't get out of bed
and someone could tell you get up dude
but like I can't move
and and worse than that I mean uh the
past two years especially it's gotten to
the point where like uh you know I've
I've wished for death I've prayed for
death
um
not because I want to die but because I
I don't know that anybody dealing with
the mental illness like truly wants to
die I think they want the pain to stop
that's right that's 100 so
yeah and and I mean I don't want to say
good things have come out of this but
some I guess because uh
in the early days of this you know I did
drink and I did do some some foolishness
and now I'm very careful not to do that
stuff because it just makes it worse for
me and probably for everybody but so I
don't do that I don't do drugs or
anything
um okay so let me
this is gonna sound like a strange
question
but alcohol worked right
even definitely gave me something there
you go
so my question right now is like I'm
really really proud of you for stepping
away because you're doing stuff that you
knew in the short term and the long term
were no good
they made you less versions of yourself
but often the I'm trying to think it's I
don't know if it's
Adler
one of the famous psychologists said
something profound that has stuck with
me they said I thought that if I took
away my clients depression and anxiety I
would make them whole
and what I found is when I took away
their depression anxiety I made them
empty
and there was nothing to backfill it
and so you've stopped doing these tough
things
what have you done in their place
um I definitely uh at the time I was
drinking and doing dumb stuff I was
um
I grew up religious and I definitely
wasn't for a long time I definitely had
some
anger there I've been trying to turn
that around for several years just
because hold on
stop going to war with Z I like you
can I tell you that
yeah
um
I like you
like I think you would be my friend
hopefully and I I
I've been through dude I've been through
profound Seasons years at a time when I
would say functioning atheist I've been
a functioning atheist in religious
environments where my job like part of
my job was my belief structure
right and there's a difference between
going to war with myself
and it's like going outside and staring
at the sky and demanding that it looked
green and it's like it does it just
looks blue and I can squeeze my hands
real tight and I can bang my head
against the hood of my car it's right
now it looks green man I mean this looks
blue I can't make them look green and so
there was that switch for me that was
I'm just gonna quit going to war with
myself
I I will have people in my life that
hold my actions accountable when it
comes to belief and it comes to feelings
mind systems are just not don't work
that great sometimes and so I'm gonna be
I'm gonna hold them really really
loosely
and I know some religious structures
would I don't I don't know your
background with that
the the looser you hold it the more they
tell you you're failing and that you're
hated and that you're not loved and I
want to tell you that's nonsense and
it's bull crap
yeah it's not true
okay well and I've been I've been lucky
to have good people in my life who
awesome never made me feel like I was uh
what would you call it like
defective in that regard or that I
wasn't trying hard enough awesome
um they've just been like you know just
keep moving forward uh you know it
doesn't matter like if you have
a lot of faith or a little faith just
hold on to what you have and and don't
let go of it and sometimes sometimes
there's going through the motions I'm
gonna do the right things even though I
don't know what I'm doing right so some
of that too right yeah but that can feel
really feel really Hollow
yes yeah
and you know the people who have known
me the longest they can tell that they
can perceive that
um
but
definitely
um so bring me to right now where are
you right now
well the thing I was going to mention
earlier is so in the middle of it um
I had a little girl born and she's she
is now nine she has been uh
she's never known me without it and
she's seen a lot and
probably had to put up with a lot as
kids do that
I don't want to say is uh bad but maybe
not typical and have you hit your kid
do you love your kid
I do yes do you scream and yell in her
face actually
if you don't mind like one of your the
First shows I ever heard from you was a
about a dad who
had left his daughter and I was
mind-boggled the whole time and I heard
your reaction and I was like yeah that's
me like I would rather I think I'd
rather die than
you split from my daughter but uh yeah I
do love her and so let me say this
definitely she's she's probably doing
pretty good
I hope so I do no I'm telling you right
now she's probably doing pretty good
yeah I mean there's some basic things
you can do to hurt her outside neglect
and outright physical and emotional
psychological abuse doesn't sound like
that
I can imagine you feel like you're
talking with a blanket over your head or
you're talking with tutor and you're
underwater that's depression right
right Hey listen to me she hears you and
she loves you
yeah she definitely does okay definitely
does you have an external voice that has
the stories you tell yourself so you
read that book
oh you have these stories we're born
into we have these stories that we're
told and over time those stories become
the stories we tell ourselves
yeah and depression is actually the main
story is just depression telling me that
I've failed everybody and I've failed
myself and I I'm not where I should be
that's right and all of that none of
that is true
none of it
and the challenge is how can I come to a
place of belief and Truth in how do I
challenge that story over time right and
continue to function in the day-to-day
you got to change the oil on this car
while you're moving right while you're
driving down the road that's tough
that's a tall order
right
have you reached the point where you're
done
you get really close to being just
exhausted
yeah it's been happening more and more
in the past like in the past years
especially where I just don't know how
to carry on okay
and I mean she's not getting any younger
either she's going to need me even more
in the future
she won't be better off with you gone
yeah and my promise if you're new to the
shows I won't lie to you
and I would tell you if you need to get
your get out of your child's life I
think I've done that before on this show
your daughter will not be better off
with yelling here
your daughter has a an immense ringside
seat
to a dad who's experiencing challenges
and continues to get up and do hard
things
for himself and for those he loves and
cares about which long term can be a
I I can't think of a higher gift and
honor you could hand your kid
and so far from robbing her of some
childhood that is is was a fantasy to
begin with
you're actually giving her some pretty
extraordinary opportunities
to learn and grow and see and experience
and empathize and feel
she's lucky to have you as her dad
so I stop
I hope so I don't know I'm telling you
and I don't know my own words but don't
give up on yourself
well I can tell you this this is my
belief
I think if she wasn't here
to kind of feel like a lighthouse and
the in the fog of mental illness uh
I don't know that I would be here
honestly I I don't want to think that
but there's been
some close calls we'll just say okay
have you tried
have I tried I I've luckily
called somebody before as I was on the
way to that good
do you do you promise me in front of all
these people listening and your daughter
that you will always make that call
yes
okay
and I do you know I just for your own
knowledge like
I do uh therapy regular
um I am trying to find the right
medication it's been kind of a long list
of strikeouts so there's there's another
side to that right and let's just call
it what it is that's my community right
the Mental Health Community that's
that's where I was born and raised
right right but there's a point on the
back side of a lot of counseling
in the back side of the
medication Merry-Go-Round that
everything feels like a waste of time
yes yep and it almost there's almost a
compounding effect this doesn't it's not
gonna work for me foreign
right yeah absolutely
have they given you exercises
it's the l-dubs man little wins
have they walked you through that
eat well yes but I've not been very good
about uh believing it I guess if that
makes sense yeah so I heard recently and
this is it was a profound like huh
somebody was asking
um
somebody about confidence and they said
after working with a bunch of leaders
and people the most confident people I
know are people who keep their promises
to themselves
right and
I think one of the roots of depression
is I have lost the ability to trust
myself
yeah yeah absolutely
and so I would agree the step out of it
yes can be talking about it
and yes absolutely
finding the right medication if you got
major depressive disorder I'm telling
you just like if you had a heart
challenge or you had knee surgery you
needed crutches for a season
finding the right medication is going to
be very important okay I have been there
my brother and they
I'm here because of it okay there's no
weakness anybody's like oh you're such
so stupid you're not I get frustrated
with my colleagues who are medical
professionals who just Sprint to that
being the first Solution on every little
discomfort that's not where you are okay
there's a difference between I keep
eating marshmallows and I throw up and
stomach cancer both of them are right
challenges with your guts one of them
takes significant intervention the other
is like hey how about you quit eating
marshmallows right so I don't want you
to beat yourself up because of what
because of the interventions you might
need to take to feel well
okay it might mean that you need to sit
down with somebody and who knows about
ketamine or you sit down with somebody
who needs to go through childhood
traumas or you need to go explore get
into medical trial for psychedelics like
there's the the treatments for retro
like in retract irrectable uh depression
right now
um
are extraordinary they're making some
significant progress
the challenges don't give up on yourself
right
right and luckily some of those
kinds of treatments like I've followed
up on and like they've they've offered
like a sliver of Hope which is is
something so so here's the thing I want
you to practice on your own will you do
will you do this okay so I I want to
make sure that you and I on the same
page you are committed to staying
connected with professionals both mental
health professionals and medical
professionals right okay cool all right
so I think my life depends on it I would
say awesome
hey mine too
yeah okay mine too
they put me under these bright lights
and I'm sitting in front of a microphone
but mine too okay
same team
yeah
um
I want you to practice something will
you practice something
yeah of course okay
I want you to
go to Walmart or go to Walgreens or one
of these little corner stores and buy a
small little journal for like nine bucks
or ten bucks okay nothing fancy here
yeah and inside of it I just want you to
write
little win number one
and then I want it to be really really
small like I will have breakfast with my
daughter two times this week that's it
and here's two things are going to
happen number one
I will have breakfast I will I
I will be throwing I will have breakfast
with her
it might be that she goes out and goes
to school gets on the bus and goes to
school and I go right back to bed for
the next two hours I will have this
breakfast
yeah and
there's going to be a voice that says
what kind of freaking loser are you you
can only have it's this much of a of an
effort to have breakfast with your
daughter God she would have been better
with any other dad in the world I want
you to write that story down
right okay you have to begin to get
those stories out of your body onto a
piece of paper where you can objectively
look at it and when it takes over your
your fight or flight response system
there is no more rational thinking about
it because your body's at War
okay
so when that story comes cool and then
here's the other story there's gonna be
a week that you can't make it you get up
for one and you can't do it
that's when the pit opens up and you
fall seven stories into the into the
black hole right
right
before you fall before you jump
I want you to be curious
not declare Civil War on yourself
so I want you to be curious about huh
what was my body protecting me from this
week that made that that exercise
that little win
really really hard
and if you approach your body with this
into curiosity instead of a sense of
Shame and you suck and Def that gets
defective and uh
there's a demo different chemical
pathway different chemical solutions to
that
that makes sense it's just a posture
yeah I'm gonna quit hating Z because you
know what nobody else does dude yeah can
I ask you a hard question
absolutely have you done stupid stuff
absolutely me too
have you been really in a dark place and
thought this is it and then you woke up
and the next day the sun came out
yeah yes me too
foreign
and maybe maybe you've never heard this
you are worth being well dude
yeah and you're worth laughing and being
silly and being goofy and saying I'm
sorry because you're gonna do more
stupid stuff for the course of your life
but most importantly you're worth not
giving up on Z
there's a despair right
continue to good on the rabbit holes for
these some of these new
um
new interventions
they're very the literature out there is
very very encouraging my private
conversations with people who've gone
through them it's extraordinary right
it's really magical
okay
but you I want to make sure we got your
promise you're not giving up on you
no Nelson because if I the way I see it
is if I give up on me I'm giving up on
the people I love and I don't want to
give up on them okay but also you can't
run your life
based on other people alone at some
point you gotta look in the mirror and
say I'm so glad that I'm here
yeah those Bonkers as everything is I'm
glad that I'm here
yeah
would you do one week of little wins and
then write me back and let me know that
you made it
yeah because if you do I'm gonna
celebrate with you
okay
is that cool yeah yeah I'll do it and
listen when I had both my knee surgeries
I had to learn how to walk again I
kicked too many people and got kicked
too much over the years
and I had to learn how to walk again and
that meant I had to have two
professionals one either side of me
holding me up well I held another little
cane thing and we took a step and then
another step right and I never saw two
this morning the squat workout I did and
then going for a run like I didn't think
that was ever gonna happen it is and so
you're gonna feel stupid and small and
little and less than by doing these
little wind exercises
all you're doing is re-teaching your
body and brain
how to feel how to win not even how to
win like how to win bro now that's what
I'm talking about but like how to
engage in life Fair yeah fair enough all
right my brother hey I love you
I love you
and you've been fighting a war that most
people have no idea about and you go to
the grocery store and you're at War and
you sit with your little daughter and
you're at War and you sit in the mirror
and you're at War
and I want you to know you're worthy of
peace
yours peace
the light's not going out man there's
still hope
I'm glad you're with us